.
Dieser Film erzählt
die Geschichte von Samuel Friedman.
Er hat sich mit elf Jahren
die Schläfenlocken abgeschnitten
und sich entschieden, auszusteigen.
Auszusteigen aus
dem streng orthodoxen Judentum,
in das er hineingeboren wurde.
Sein Weg
ist ungewiss und bisweilen einsam,
und doch führt er ihn in
die tiefen Sehnsüchte seiner Seele.
Recht früh habe ich verstanden,
dass alles,
was alle rund um mich herum inte-
ressiert, mich null interessiert.
Schon damals wusste ich,
dass mich Fussball mehr interessiert
als der liebe Gott.
Sorry, ist so.
Und ich habe schnell gewusst,
dass es irgendwann einmal
wahrscheinlich so eskalieren wird,
dass ich nicht mehr Teil dieser
Religion oder Gemeinde sein werde.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Samuel Friedman ist 39 Jahre alt.
Er arbeitet als Geschäftsführer
in einem Restaurant.
Vieles, was für die meisten Menschen
selbstverständlich ist,
musste er sich erkämpfen.
Es hat mich schon sehr lange
stark definiert.
Ich konnte damit
auch sehr lange alles erklären:
"Okay, ich weiss es nicht,
weil ich nicht so aufgewachsen bin."
Oder: "Ich kenne das so nicht."
Eine Kollegin meiner Freundin
bezeichnete mich einmal
als den Veganer unter den Juden.
Man kann keine 5 Min. mit mir reden,
ohne zu wissen,
dass ich ein Aussteiger gewesen bin
und noch immer bin.
Ja.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Sein Leben ist eng mit Zürich
verbunden, seiner Herzensstadt,
der Stadt
seines liebsten Fussballklubs,
der Stadt,
in der er auf Widerstände stösst
und trotz allem
auch Nestwärme erfährt.
Ich bin Sam.
- Freut mich, ich bin Sara.
Du hast einen Termin bei mir.
Bist du ready?- Ja.- Super.
Friedman scheut den Schmerz nicht.
Es gebe Momente im Leben,
da müsse man ihn zulassen.
So z.B. auf dem Schragen
der Tätowiererin Sara Fleur.
Sie sticht ihm eine Samurai-Maske -
sein 17. Tattoo.
Bayern München auf dem Arm
mit dem "Mia san mia".
Und "Züri isch ois" auf der Brust.
Für Zürich ...
Jedes Tattoo
hat eine andere Bedeutung.
Das Geburtsdatum meiner Tochter -
mit ihrem Namen.
Was mich im Leben bewegt,
ist der Glaube an den Erfolg.
Oder keine Angst
vor dem Scheitern zu haben,
sondern immer
an den eigenen Erfolg zu glauben.
Jedes Tattoo
hat eine andere Bedeutung,
hat einen anderen Grund.
Ein paar meiner Tattoos
liess ich einfach nur darum stechen,
weil sie schön sind.
Im Judentum
sind Tattoos nicht erlaubt.
Du wirst nicht auf einem
jüdischen Friedhof begraben,
wenn du tätowiert bist.
Ich mache das nicht als Affront.
Was die anderen Leute empfinden,
ist ihr Problem.
Das kann ich nicht steuern.
Aber ein Teil
meines Mottos ist eben:
Geh deinen eigenen Weg -
und das ist mein Weg.
Mein Weg ist voller Tattoos.
Und wem es nicht passt,
soll meinen Weg nicht kreuzen.
Dann ist auch alles gut.
* Sanfte Klarinettenklänge *
Samuel stammt aus einer
streng orthodoxen jüdischen Familie,
die Tätowiererin
aus einer syrisch-orthodoxen.
Die Religion ist ein Thema,
wohin er auch geht.
Die orthodoxen Juden in der Schweiz
sind völlig anders als in Israel.
Ja, die Gemeinde in der Schweiz
ist eben auch sehr religiös
und auch sehr verschlossen.
Ich glaube,
früher war es nicht so extrem.
In den 70er- und 80er-Jahren
war es noch anders.
Damals gingen sie öfter aus,
um einen Kaffee in einer
normalen Cafeteria zu trinken.
Aber heutzutage
ist das keine Option mehr,
das kommt gar nicht infrage.
- Krass.
Wer hatte die Idee mit dem Rot?
Ich nicht.
(Er lacht.)
Ist lustig: Egal, ob du
an Gott glaubst oder nicht,
in solchen Momenten sagst du:
"Oh, Gott!"
Oh, shit!
Yes.
Du hast es geschafft.
- Wie geil!
Geboren in Israel, kommt Samuel
Friedman mit neun Jahren nach Zürich.
Die Eltern
arbeiten in der Gastronomie.
Sie erziehen ihre fünf Kinder
mit viel Liebe und noch mehr Regeln.
Unsere Ferien haben wir
immer im Wohnwagen verbracht.
Mein Vater
war ein eingeschworener Camper.
Er war sehr anders -
innerhalb der jüdischen Gemeinde.
Es kam nicht oft vor ...
Also in Zürich waren wir die ein-
zigen, die so in die Ferien fuhren.
Wir haben die Dusche
im Campingwagen ausgebaut
und bauten stattdessen
einen grossen Kühlschrank ein,
in dem wir koscheres Fleisch in die
Ferien mit transportieren konnten.
Anfangs Sommerferien
füllten wir diesen Kühlschrank
und reisten in ganz Europa herum.
Ich hasste es.
Ich hasste
die Duschen auf den Campingplätzen.
Ich hasste es,
immer das Zelt auf- und abzubauen,
all dieser Schlamm,
wenn es geregnet hat.
Ich hasste es.
Aber trotzdem war es sehr schön.
Auf ihren Reisen erhalten die Kinder
Einblick in eine Welt,
die ihnen im Alltag in Zürich
verborgen bleibt.
Die Friedmans gehören zur ultra-
orthodoxen jüdischen Gemeinde
Agudas Achim und leben streng nach
den 613 Ge- und Verboten der Thora.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Z.B. darf den Kindern erst mit drei
Jahren die Haare geschnitten werden.
Seine Kindheit
sei behütet und voller Liebe gewesen.
Und doch spürt er schon früh,
dass ihn das Leben ausserhalb des
frommen Rahmens zwischen Synagoge,
Schule und Familie anzieht.
Ich wuchs in einer Religion auf,
in der Grenzen das Wichtigste sind,
das es gibt.
Im Judentum gibt es
nichts Wichtigeres als die Grenzen.
Meine erste Erinnerung
an meinen Zweifel
war im Prinzip völlig banal.
Es ist etwas, das ...
Bei uns zu Hause
stand ein Fernseher.
Das war damals
in jüdischen Kreisen nicht normal,
Wir durften auch
nicht darüber sprechen.
Wir hatten zwar einen Fernseher,
aber wenn wir Gäste hatten,
verschwand er im Schrank.
Als Kind habe ich mich
in diesem Moment gefragt:
Warum haben wir einen Fernseher,
wenn man keinen haben darf?
Da habe ich realisiert,
dass es eine Grauzone gibt.
Und ich fragte mich:
Wie grau ist diese Zone?
Was kann ich sonst noch alles tun,
ohne darüber zu erzählen?
Wo sind denn
die eigentlichen Grenzen?
Mit elf Jahren trifft Samuel
eine Entscheidung fürs Leben.
Er schneidet sich die Schläfenlocken
ab, sein erster Akt der Rebellion.
Sie symbolisieren ziemlich viel.
Dadurch bist du gekennzeichnet, bist
mit einem Brandzeichen versehen.
Das wollte ich nicht mehr.
Das war der Tag,
der mein Leben veränderte.
Und wie fiel die Reaktion
z.B. deiner Mutter aus?
Für eine Antwort
muss ich erst etwas ausholen.
Meine Eltern sind
nicht ultraorthodox aufgewachsen.
Sie haben ...
Sie wurden später frömmer,
wie man so sagt.
Sie wurden schwärzer,
wenn man das so sagen darf.
Und darum war für sie
das Abschneiden der Schläfenlocken
zwar nicht unbedingt okay, aber ...
... irgendwie verstanden sie
es wahrscheinlich auch,
weil sie auch die andere,
die normale religiöse Welt kennen,
wo nicht alle Schläfenlocken haben.
Das ist eher
ein Kennzeichen des Chassidismus,
das Tragen
von langen Schläfenlocken.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Natürlich ist es aufgefallen,
natürlich hat man
mich darauf angesprochen,
aber ich realisierte oder
begann schon damals zu realisieren,
dass es mir egal ist,
was andere über mich denken.
* Lebendige Klavierklänge *
In der Schweiz
gibt es insgesamt 18'000 Juden.
Ein kleiner, aber
auffälliger Teil davon, knapp 3'000,
gehört zur ultraorthodoxen jüdischen
Gemeinschaft in Zürich Wiedikon.
Es ist eine konservative,
gar geschlossene Gemeinschaft,
die sich abgrenzen will.
Die Männer in schwarzen Anzügen und
Hut, die Frauen mit Rock und Perücke.
* Lebendige Geigenklänge *
Der jüdische Journalist
Yves Kugelmann
kennt die immensen Widerstände,
die ein Aussteiger
wie Samuel Friedman überwinden muss,
wenn er die Gemeinschaft verlässt.
Ultraorthodoxe Gemeinschaften
sind totalitäre Gemeinschaften,
in denen ein Rabbinat bestimmt
und massiv ins persönliche Leben
des Individuums eingreift,
wenn es überhaupt so etwas
wie ein persönliches Leben hat.
D.h., man wird
weitgehend entindividualisiert,
man wird weitgehend fremdbestimmt.
Aber für viele ist das
gar kein so harter Wechsel,
weil sie ja schon so aufwachsen.
Die Eltern in diesen Familien
leben eben auch schon so
und werden auch schon von den
Rabbinaten weitgehend dominiert
in ihrem Alltag.
D.h., von aussen
nimmt man das stärker wahr,
oder im Prozess der Ablösung, wenn
man alles zu hinterfragen beginnt
und versucht, das in Einklang
zu bringen mit der Umwelt,
in der man lebt.
Hier im Zürcher Kreis 3
hat Samuel Friedman den grössten Teil
seiner Kindheit verbracht,
eine Kindheit
geprägt von Regeln und Normen.
Die Männer beten zwei- bis dreimal
täglich in der Synagoge,
die Kinder besuchen eine nach
Geschlecht getrennte jüdische Schule.
Hörst du sie?
- Wer ist das?
Es hat hier noch immer eine Schule,
die jetzt gegenüber
unserer alten Schule steht.
Weststrasse -
das war unsere Hood, fertig.
Unsere Leute wohnen
nicht weit links oder rechts davon.
Alle meine Kindheitserinnerungen
stammen von hier,
im Umkreis von 200 m
von diesem Platz.
"Auspuff der Nation"
nannte man damals
in den 90ern die Zürcher Weststrasse.
Der Schwerverkehr wälzte sich
zweispurig durch die Quartierstrasse.
Eine Russschicht überzog die Häuser.
Viele jüdische Familien
wohnen immer noch hier -
in Gehdistanz zu ihrer Synagoge.
Unsere Schule war in einem
dieser alten verkackten Häuser -
im ersten Stock,
also im Hochparterre.
Unsere Schule befand sich
in einer 5-Zimmerwohnung
oder 6-Zimmerwohnung -
wir waren sechs Klassen.
Jede Klasse war in einem Zimmer.
Wir bekamen Unterricht
hauptsächlich in jüdischen Fächern:
Thora, Talmud,
all diese Sachen eben.
Dieser Unterricht dauert bis 15 Uhr.
Dann von 15-17 oder 18 Uhr hatten
wir noch schnell 3 Std. Unterricht
in Mathematik,
Englisch, Französisch.
Das waren die
etwas profaneren Fächer,
damit sie doch etwas
Unterstützung vom Staat erhalten,
denn sonst
würden sie keine erhalten.
* Lebendige Geigenklänge *
Bei uns war von 7-19 Uhr Programm:
Morgens um 7 Uhr
stehst du in der Synagoge,
abends um 19 Uhr
gehst du nach Hause.
Den ganzen Tag
verbrachten wir gut behütet ...
... in der Gemeinde.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Mit 14 zog ich von Zürich weg
ins Internat.
Einer meiner Rabbiner
in der Schule sagte:
"Es ist alles verboten, ausser das,
von dem man dir sagt,
dass es erlaubt sei -
und das ist Atmen.
Im Internat
habe ich dieses Spiel mitgespielt.
Ich habe dort die Matura
auf höchstem Niveau abgeschlossen,
ich habe dort
mein Studium abgeschlossen
und tat so, als ob.
Erst nachher habe ich
die Kippa komplett gewechselt
und auch meine Kleidung.
Das war ...
Das war die erste permanente ...
... Berührung mit dem ...
... freien Leben.
Lustigerweise nennt man
auf Jiddisch jemanden,
der nicht religiös ist: fray.
Ja, ich wurde frei.
Die gewonnene Freiheit schmeckt ihm,
sie riecht aber auch
nach Alkohol, Drogen und Pokerspiel.
Im Rausch versucht er herauszufinden,
wer er ist,
und nimmt einige Irrfahren auf sich.
Dinge, auf die er
jahrelang verzichtet hat,
lebt er nun exzessiv aus ...
... wie das Rauchen am Sabbat.
Ja, es war wie das Outing -
eine Art religiöses Coming-out.
Schliesslich verliess ich eine Welt,
die ich kannte,
in Richtung einer Welt,
die ich zwar gesehen hatte,
aber nicht richtig kannte.
Ich wusste nicht genau,
was mich erwarten würde.
Und ich wusste nicht,
ob meine Familie mitmachen würde.
Wenn ich ihnen zu Hause sagte:
"Hey, Leute, ich glaube nicht mehr,
was ihr glaubt."
Würden sie dann antworten:
"Dort ist die Tür, auf Wiedersehen."
Ich fragte mich, ob ich es
wirklich durchziehen wollte.
Es gibt eine Szene im Schweizer Film
"Wolkenbruchs wunderliche Reise
in die Arme einer Schickse",
als er im Hotel durchdreht,
nachdem er kapiert hat,
dass er eigentlich alle verloren
hat, von links und von rechts.
* Klagender Gesang *
* Er spricht Hebräisch. *
Diese Szene dauert etwa 5 Min.
Bei mir dauerte sie etwa fünf Jahre.
Was guckst du?
Haben Sie vielleicht
einen guten Ratschlag?
Aus dem einstigen Vorbeter
Samuel Friedman
wird ein nicht religiöser Mensch,
der völlig anders lebt,
als er erzogen wurde.
Das jüdische Leben, der jüdische
Alltag ist sehr gemeinschaftlich,
einerseits in der Familie,
aber v.a. unter den Männern,
die sich täglich ein- bis zweimal
in der Synagoge zum Gebet treffen
und auch zusammen lernen.
Viele der Tage und Perioden im Jahr
besitzen einen grossen
gemeinschaftlichen Anteil,
den man natürlich radikal verliert.
Man verliert seine Umgebung.
Das ist eine Gemeinschaft,
und nicht unbedingt Freunde,
wie wir es verstehen,
für die man sich entscheidet,
sondern es ist eine Gemeinschaft,
in der man zusammen den Alltag lebt,
woraus sich menschliche Beziehungen
ergeben - und das fällt weg.
Man wird also sozusagen über Nacht
von allem abgekapselt,
was einem vertraut, lieb
und auch nicht fremd gewesen ist.
Man wird
in die totale Fremde entlassen.
Dadurch wird leicht
und rasch ein Trauma ausgelöst,
weil das massive
existenzielle Brüche sind.
Das kann sich jeder vorstellen,
denn das beschränkt sich
nicht nur auf die jüdische Thematik.
Das sind massive Ereignisse.
Je nachdem,
wie stark die Persönlichkeit ist,
schlägt das völlig anders zu.
Samuel Friedman arbeitet heute
als Geschäftsführer in
einem japanischen Fusion-Restaurant.
Nach seiner Zeit im Internat
in Israel heiratet er eine Jüdin.
Sie bekommen eine Tochter,
doch die Ehe hält nicht lange.
Sie haben das gemeinsame Sorgerecht.
Das Verhältnis zur Ex-Frau
sei aber schwierig.
Die Tochter und er hingegen
seien sich sehr nahe.
Zweimal pro Woche
übernachte sie bei ihm.
In diesem Film auftreten
will sie lieber nicht.
* Er spricht Hebräisch. *
Was für ein Chef ist er?
Er ist ein sehr flexibler
und offener Chef.
Man kann mit allem zu ihm kommen,
kann mit ihm über alles reden.
Das finde ich super.
Oft sagt er erst:
"Nein, das geht nicht."
Aber schliesslich
geht es dann schon.
Aber genau das
schätze ich sehr an ihm.
Fast hättest du mir geglaubt.
- Du bist so ein Schmock.
Manchmal schreit er viel rum,
das mag ich nicht so.
Ich bin eine Person,
die v.a. unter Stress ruhig wird,
während Sam eher etwas lauter wird.
Da zeigt sich der Hooligan in mir.
Der Ablösungsprozess
ging schrittweise vonstatten.
Obwohl er schon
als Kind anzuecken begann,
hat er erst vor sechs Jahren
das letzte äusserliche Symbol
der Zugehörigkeit
zur jüdischen Religion,
die Kippa auf dem Kopf,
abgelegt.
Anfangs habe er sich nackt gefühlt.
Der eingeschlagene Weg wurde zur
Zerreissprobe für die ganze Familie,
v.a. seinen Eltern
habe er sehr viel zugemutet.
Zipora Friedman arbeitet
als Köchin in einer jüdischen Schule.
Einmal pro Woche ist Samuel
bei seinen Eltern zu Hause.
Ich habe zum Teil viele krasse
Gewichtsveränderungen durchgemacht.
Als Kind war ich sehr dick.
Wenn ich abgenommen hatte,
nahm ich nachher wieder stark zu.
Das begleitet mich
schon mein ganzes Leben.
Bei uns zu Hause
gab es immer leckeres Essen.
Beide Eltern können super kochen,
meine Mutter bäckt super,
Bei uns hatte es keine Schublade
voll mit Süssigkeiten,
sondern einen Schrank voll.
Esssen war immer ...
auch bei meiner Grossmutter,
wenn ich sie besuchte,
war ihre erste Frage nicht:
"Wie geht es dir?", sondern:
"Hast du gegessen? Hast du Hunger?"
"Setz dich und iss!"
Das Essen kommt an erster Stelle.
Sie gehört zur Generation
der Holocaust-Überlebenden.
Sie war in Auschwitz,
wo sie nichts zu essen hatten.
Deshalb hat sie sich geschworen:
"Etwas, was nie fehlen wird,
ist das Essen."
* Sie sprechen Hebräisch. *
Er fuhr zum Lernen nach Israel.
Eines Tages rief er mich an:
"Mami, darf ich
meine Kippa tauschen?"
Von der jüdischen Kopfbedeckung,
der Kippa,
gibt es Varianten
verschiedener Abstufungen.
Damals trug er
eine schwarze Samt-Kippa.
Er sagte mir,
das entspreche ihm nicht:
"Das bin ich nicht."
Ich antwortete:
"Du bist erwachsen genug,
um deine Kippa zu tauschen,
wie immer du willst."
Nach ein paar Monaten
rief er mich wieder an:
Er wollte die Kippa
einer noch niedrigeren Abstufung.
Damals dachte ich,
das sei die letzte Stufe.
Wenn er jeweils
in die Schweiz zurückkehrte,
trug er immer die Kippa,
feierte mit uns Sabbat
und ass immer koscher.
Zu Hause war er normal wie immer.
Ich hielt ihn für religiös,
aber im Hintergrund
war er es nicht mehr.
Das habe ich nur langsam erfahren.
Er war schon verheiratet,
hatte schon eine Tochter,
das war ein Schock für mich.
Das war ein Schock.
Aber er ist mein Sohn.
Ich kann es nicht anders ausdrücken:
Er ist mein Sohn.
Mit Gott muss er seine Rechnung
selbst austragen, nicht mit mir.
Er weiss,
dass er mir alles bedeutet.
Sind Sie trotzdem stolz auf ihn?
- Sehr, sehr.
Wäre es nicht noch schöner,
wenn er auch religiös wäre?
Dafür bete ich jeden Tag.
Ja, dass er zurück nach Hause kommt,
wie ich es einmal nennen will.
Ich bete jeden Tag dafür,
dass er eine jüdische Frau
kennen und lieben lernt,
und eine jüdische Familie gründet.
Dafür bete ich jeden Tag.
Mein Vater
hatte seine liebe Mühe damit.
Wir hatten eine Zeit,
in der wir wenig bis gar nicht
miteinander kommunizierten,
und wenn,
dann war es relativ zerstritten.
Wir diskutierten über Sachen,
von denen er fand:
"So musst du es machen."
Ich hingegen fand:
"Du kannst mich nicht dazu zwingen."
Ich habe Glück,
dass sie mich so akzeptiert haben.
Das zu akzeptieren,
fällt vielen schwer.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie es in der Schweiz steht,
aber wir hören,
dass viele in Israel
das leider nicht akzeptieren können.
Aber wie ich schon gesagt habe:
Er ist mein Sohn.
Ich liebe ihn.
Ich habe, Gott sei Dank, fünf
Kinder, und er ist eines davon.
die ich alle gleich liebe.
Der eine ist klüger,
die andere schöner,
aber für mich sind meine Kinder
wie die Finger meiner Hand.
Bei uns zu Hause steht ein
klassischer jüdischer Bücherschrank,
in dem die fünf Bücher Moses
in verschiedenen Varianten stehen.
Sie stehen hier
in verschiedenen Ausführungen.
Alle diese
drei mehrteiligen Buchbände
beinhalten verschiedene Erklärungen
für die fünf Bücher Moses.
Dann gibt es für die 613 Lebens-
regeln in den fünf Bücher Moses,
die Mischna, das sind
Erklärungen für diese Regeln.
Und darauf basiert der Talmud,
das sind all diese blauen Buchbände.
Der Talmud ist sozusagen
das jüdische Gesetzbuch,
das jeden Teil des Lebens,
jeden Lebensabschnitt,
jede Situation,
die im Alltag passieren kann,
einordnet, behandelt und analysiert.
Von familiären Angelegenheiten
wie Heirat und Scheidung
bis zu Themen wie Geld ausleihen.
Wenn du etwas an einen Freund
ausleihst und es geht kaputt,
wird im Talmud geregelt,
wer schuld ist.
Also wirklich jede Situation
im Leben wird zerpflückt.
Der Talmud ist in verschiedene
Themenbereiche aufgeteilt.
In der Mitte steht der Hauptteil,
links und rechts davon steht
die eine und andere Erklärung dafür,
dann stehen noch weitere Erklärungen
am Rand der Seiten.
Und all das wird
in den Jugendjahren gelernt,
so ab der vierten
oder fünften Klasse.
Bis zur vierten und fünften Klasse
lernt man die fünf Bücher Moses
und die Mischna,
dann beginnt man mit dem Talmud,
den man eigentlich nie zu Ende
lernt, es geht immer weiter.
Wenn ich eine Frage
z.B. zum Sabbat habe,
dann gibt es ein Buch dafür,
in dem ich nachschlagen kann,
was ich
in dieser Situation tun darf.
Dann ist es geklärt und geht gut.
Ja, klare Regeln, viele Regeln.
Viele Regeln, an die wir uns halten.
- Wir versuchen es.
Wir geben unser Bestes.
Oder?
- Ja, das ist so.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Stell dir vor, Sabbat
endet im Sommer um 22.30 Uhr.
Den ganzen Tag darf man keine Elek-
trizität benutzen, nicht fernsehen.
Man liest ein oder zwei Bücher,
aber dann hat man genug.
Dann isst man etwas und noch etwas,
aber irgendwann ist man satt.
Wir spielten entweder
Uno, Monopoly oder Lego.
Wenn die Kinder gespielt haben,
waren sie zu 100 % beschäftigt.
Ja, sicher.- Und dann gab es
auch noch diese Malbücher
Aber am Sabbat
darf man nicht malen.-  Nein.
Man darf nicht zeichnen,
nicht schreiben.- Nein.
Das ist alles verboten.
- Wieso denn?
Weil es verboten ist, sagte Gott.
* Sie sprechen Hebräisch. *
Am Sabbat darf nichts erschaffen,
nichts Neues kreieren.
Theoretisch darf man auch
nicht bauen.
Aber Lego ist etwas anderes,
weil Bauten aus Lego
nicht dauerhaft sind,
man kann sie wieder kaputt machen.
Aber es gibt solche,
die dann nicht einmal Lego spielen.
Ich würde wetten,
dass es solche gibt,
die sagen,
dass Lego auch verboten sei.
Das können wir noch recherchieren.
Aber eigentlich darf man
an Sabbat sehr vieles nicht tun,
das ist der Tag,
an dem die meisten Verbote gelten.
Der Spielplatz ist erlaubt,
Spazieren am Sabbat ist schön.
Aber man darf am Sabbat
z.B. nicht schwimmen.
Schwimmen darf man nicht,
weil man
vielleicht ertrinken könnte.
Wenn man sich
vor dem Ertrinken retten will
und sich an ein Stück Holz klammert,
erschafft man dadurch ein Boot,
was wiederum verboten ist.
Man darf kein Boot erschaffen.
* Sie sprechen Hebräisch. *
* Gemütliche Ziehharmonikaklänge *
Wie seine Eltern wohnt
auch Samuel in Zürich Wiedikon -
zusammen mit seiner Freundin.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Lebst du?
- Ja.
Hallo.
- Hallo, Schatz, geht's gut?
Es ist etwas unordentlich hier.
Ich weiss nicht, ob es hält.
Samuel ist erfolgreich im Job.
In der Liebe hat er
schon ein paar Anläufe genommen.
Dieses Mal hofft er inständig,
dass es hält.
Seit eineinhalb Jahren
ist er mit Bigna zusammen.
Dass seine Freundin nicht Jüdin ist,
scheint keinen von beiden zu stören.
Dass Bigna hingegen
alleine wohnen möchte
und deswegen wieder auszieht
aus der gemeinsamen Wohnung,
das fällt Samuel
schwer zu akzeptieren.
* Er summt Melodie. *
Wieso herrscht bei dir
eine solche Unordnung?
Weil Bigna umzieht.
Und ich bin
natürlich betroffen davon.
Mein Zimmer dient
als Ablagefläche für ihre Sachen,
bevor sie dann
wegtransportiert werden.
Ja, es ist okay.
Am Anfang hatte ich
etwas Mühe mit dieser Entscheidung,
nach dem Zusammenwohnen
wieder nicht zusammen zu wohnen.
Ich fand es erst seltsam,
aber als sie erklärte,
warum sie diesen Schritt machen
muss, war es okay.
Jeder muss seinen Weg gehen.
Ich bin der Letzte,
der im Weg steht,
wenn jemand seinen eigenen Weg
gehen will - und soll.
Darum geht es.
Sie muss den Schritt wagen,
allein zu wohnen.
Da bin ich der Letzte, der sagt:
"Nein."
"Ich will das nicht,
du musst hierblieben."
Du kannst niemanden
zu seinem Glück zwingen.
So herum? Nein, so.
Ich versuche, vernünftig zu sein.
Es ist Teil des neuen Sam, andere
so zu akzeptieren, wie sie sind,
und so vernünftig
wie möglich zu sein.
Als geschiedener Mann weiss ich,
was geht und was nicht.
Ich kenne meine Grenzen recht gut.
Spätestens dann
lernst du deine Grenzen kennen.
Ich nehme doch Sachen mit,
die ich nachher wegschmeissen werde,
aber ich habe
schon vieles entrümpelt.
Solange ich nicht entrümpelt wurde,
ist alles gut: Ich bin noch hier.
Kuckuck. Tschau.
Die ultraorthodoxe Gemeinde
in Zürich Wiedikon ist klein.
Man kennt sich.
Wenn Samuel hier unterwegs ist,
ruft seine Anwesenheit ein breites
Spektrum an Gefühlsregungen hervor.
* Er spricht Hebräisch.*
Heee!
- He, Tomer!
* Sie sprechen Hebräisch. *
Mit Kamera.
Mit Mikrofon und Kamera.
Und du? Wohin gehst du?
Ich kaufe Hummus in Koscher City.
- Das beste Hummus.
Ist dein Vater in der Synagoge?
- Wie?
- Ich weiss nicht.
Sein Auto steht dort, aber
vielleicht ist es ein ähnliches.
Sie haben alle ähnliche Autos.
Es ist zwar kein Toyota Previa,
aber auch ein Siebensitzer.
Sali, Janco.
Anfragen für Drehbewilligungen
wurden alle abgelehnt.
Es dauert auch hier nicht lange,
da wird das Kamerateam draussen
um Samuel Friedman entdeckt.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Sie begleiten mich heute.
Wir sind
mit Samuel Friedmann unterwegs.
Guten Morgen.
- Wir filmen nur auf der Strasse.
(Security-Mann)
Hier ist es immer etwas gefährlich,
deshalb wollen wir wissen, wer ihr
seid.- Wir sind mit ihm unterwegs.
Wir müssen hier aufpassen.
- Okay, klar, danke.
Weshalb müssen wir aufpassen?
Weisst du, sobald du
das Gebäude filmst, kommen sie.
Sofort stehen alle da, weil
alle interessiert, was passiert.
Das ist typisch.
Aber es gibt immerhin noch ein
paar wenige, die wenigstens grüssen.
Hopfen und Malz
sind noch nicht verloren.
Wenn du dich hier bewegst,
ist das ein freundlicher Ort?
Oder ist es für dich eher schwierig?
Ich habe kein Problem damit.
Ich bin sozial und grüsse alle.
aber sie sind
nicht unbedingt Fans von mir.
Sie denken von mir ...
Ich habe eine Tür aufgestossen ...
Vor mir
ist lange niemand ausgestiegen,
nach mir ist auch
lange niemand mehr ausgestiegen.
Es ist etwas,
das nicht gern gesehen wird,
dass jemand, der ausgestiegen ist,
Erfolg haben kann,
dass es ihm gut geht und er
noch Kontakt zu seiner Familie hat.
Und dann ist er noch so frech und
kauft Hummus hier unter ihrer Nase.
Das gefällt ihnen nicht unbedingt.
Aber ... ja.
Für mich kam Wegziehen nie infrage.
Und v.a. wohin?
Soll ich nach Israel zurück?
Dort kann der Druck derselbe sein.
Ich habe dort auch Familie,
die ultraorthodox ist.
In einem anderen Land
ein neues Leben zu beginnen ...
Ich meine, ich habe eine Tochter.
Das würde ich ihr
nicht antun wollen.
So gesehen: Nein, Zürich.
Jetzt schicken sie
mir schon Nachrichten.
Super.
- Wer denn?
Irgend jemand
von der Gemeinde fragt,
wie lange diese Aufnahmen
noch dauern werden.
Hoppla! In diesem Fall
haben sie noch immer meine Nummer.
Spannend.- Wer hat dir
eine Nachricht geschickt?
Einer, der mit mir
in derselben Klasse war.
Ich habe recht früh verstanden,
dass all das,
was rundum alle interessiert,
mich null interessiert,
weder die Religionsgeschichte,
noch der Glaube oder Gott.
Heilig sein und Gott dienen,
den lieben langen Tag nur in
der Synagoge sitzen und lernen ...
Schon mit zehn oder elf wusste ich,
dass ich das nicht will.
Schon damals wusste ich,
dass mich Fussball mehr interessiert
als der liebe Gott.
Sorry, ist so.
* Fussball-Fangesang *
Der Fussball
ist Friedmans Religionsersatz.
Als das engmaschige Netz
der ultraorthodox jüdischen
Gemeinschaft reisst,
lässt er sich
vom Fussball auffangen und treiben.
Als Vermummter der Südkurve
war auch er einer,
der Petarden zündete und sich gar
Gefechte mit der Polizei lieferte.
Vor ein paar Jahren hat er aufgehört,
sich zu vermummen,
Vollblutfan ist er noch immer.
# Sing so laut, wie du nur kannst.
# Schliess dich diesen Kranken an.
# Auch wenn die Welt
bald untergehen wird.
# Stehen wir immer für dich da.
Ich verliess eine Gemeinde,
Gemeinschaft oder Community.
Und ich wurde aufgefangen
von einer anderen Gemeinschaft,
in der Gott nicht im Himmel ist,
sondern auf dem Rasen Fussball
spielt - und Maradona heisst
oder Messi oder Cristiano Ronaldo
oder Blerim Dzemaili.
Ja, das ist schon ...
... ein Ersatz.
Es ist eben schon
nicht dasselbe, verdammt!
* Fussball-Fangesang *
Es macht den Anschein,
als sei Samuel schon ein paar Mal vor
einem drohenden Abgrund umgekehrt,
als hätte er die Kurve
im letzten Moment noch gekriegt -
Verluste nimmt er in Kauf.
Für ihn gilt: alles oder nichts.
Er wirkt hart und abgeklärt
und doch trägt er seine Familie
und Freunde fest im Herzen.
* Sanfte Klavier- und Geigenklänge *
So auch an diesem Morgen.
Samuel ist seit dem Morgengrauen
auf den Beinen.
Bereits vor der Arbeit
hat er etwas gemacht,
von dem er wohl selber dachte,
dass er das nie mehr tun würde.
Er hat gebetet.
Der Vater einer Freundin
ist gestorben.
Dann sitzt man
sieben Tage lang zu Hause.
Man sitzt auf niederen Stühlen
und trauert.
Jeden Morgen
betet man das Morgengebet.
Weil sie in Küsnacht
und nicht in der Stadt wohnen,
haben sie zu wenig
Männer,
denn es braucht zehn Männer
für das Morgengebet.
Deshalb fragte sie mich
um Unterstützung.
Man beginnt den Morgen
mit einem Ritual.
Dafür zieht man sog. Gebetsbänder
an, das sind solche Lederriemen.
Aus Tradition
habe ich diese angezogen.
Damit habe ich sie unterstützt.
Ich durfte auch vorbeten ...
... das erste Mal wieder
nach 20 Jahren.
Aber es ist wie velofahren,
man verlernt es nie.
Die Gebetsriemen über den Tattoos
anzuziehen, ist seltsam:
Schizophrenie in Person.
Mir bedeutet es nichts, aber
wenn es ihr hilft, ist es schön.
Sie ist auch nicht religiös,
aber wenn jemand stirbt,
lebt man die Traditionen
etwas mehr aus als sonst im Alltag.
Ich glaube,
ihrer Mutter ist es sehr wichtig.
Darum: Wenn ich helfen kann, helfe
ich gerne, das ist kein Problem.
Als ich meiner Mutter
am Telefon davon erzählt habe,
hat sie sich mega darüber gefreut.
Sie war mega happy.
Stolz.
- Hofft sie, dass du zurückfindest?
Ja, sie begann schon zu träumen.
Nein, no chance!
Aber es ist okay, träumen darf man.
Das ist erlaubt.
Jüdisch zu sein
scheint mehr zu bedeuten,
als an Gott zu glauben
und Gebote zu achten.
Samuel Friedman, der Aussteiger,
der Mann, der vermeintlich
gebrochen hat mit seiner Religion,
trägt in seinem tiefsten Innern
eine jüdische Identität,
auf die er sehr stolz ist.
Einmal pro Woche trainiert er
die G-Junioren des
jüdischen Fussballvereins FC Hakoah.
Die Schriftkapsel am Türrahmen
zu küssen, hat er verinnerlicht.
Bisweilen ist er irritiert
über seine Gewohnheiten,
die er auch nach Jahren
nicht abzulegen vermag.
In normalen Häusern
gibt es das nicht,
nur in Häusern mit jüdischem Bezug
gibt es das.
Aber ich weiss genau,
wo es sich befindet,
ich muss nicht einmal hinschauen -
so krank.
Unter den Eltern der Kinder,
die er trainiert,
sind auch
ultraorthodox jüdische dabei.
Bisher hätten alle
sehr gut auf ihn reagiert.
Heute werden sie motiviert sein.
* Sie sprechen Hebräisch. *
Kannst du mir meine Schuhe binden?
- Ja.
Hast du uns was gekauft?
- Nein, heute nicht.
aber nächste Woche vielleicht
wieder, wenn ihr heute gut spielt.
Also, Liad ist erster,
bitte reiht euch hinter ihm ein.
Aufwärmen.
Also, es wird nicht überholt.
Wir joggen,
wir rennen nicht, verstanden?
Wir wärmen uns auf,
langsam, und laufen.
* Pfiff *
Schön gespielt, Amos.
Hast du einen Schlag
gegen den Fuss bekommen?
Zeig mal. Versuche, ihn zu strecken.
Drücke jetzt dagegen.
Wow! Du bist so stark!
Also, aufstehen.
Also, Freistoss für Ilan,
alle weg, alle raus.
Weiterspielen, es ist
nichts passiert, weiterspielen.
Ich bin stolz auf meine Herkunft.
Ich bin stolz auf mein Volk.
Und das hat jetzt nichts mit
dem Judentum als Religion zu tun.
* Entspannte Musik *
Mein Instagram Name lautet:
zurichjew
Wieso?
- Ich fand ihn einfach lustig.
Einerseits engt es dich ein,
und du willst dich davon befreien,
andererseits bist du stolz darauf
und willst es hervorheben.
Kannst du mir das erklären?
Vermutlich kann ich es
nicht erklären.
Es war eine Befreiung
von dieser Einengung, ja,
von allem, was nicht erlaubt ist,
aber das Judentum
hat auch sehr schöne Seiten.
Das Familiäre ist sehr schön,
das Familienleben ist super.
Traditionen sind an und für sich
keine schlechte Sache.
Wenn ich an die Melodien,
an die Lieder denke,
die sind wirklich sehr schön.
Manchmal ertappe ich mich,
wenn ich irgendwo eine Melodie höre,
dass ich mitsinge oder
das Lied in meinem Kopf mit summe.
Und ich finde das ...
... ein schöner Teil des Judentums..
Nicht das Erzwungene,
nicht das "Du musst!",
sondern die anderen Sachen,
die sehr schön sind.
Ich weiss nicht, warum man nicht
das eine haben kann ohne das andere.
Das geht eigentlich - man kann.
* Lebhafte Gitarrenklänge *
So gerne Samuel über die Abzweigungen
in seinem selber Leben entscheidet,
so schmerzhaft kann es sein, wenn
jemand anderes diesen Part übernimmt.
Samuels Freundin
hat sich von ihm getrennt.
Das Leben ist passiert.
Ja, ich bin traurig.
Das ist mir sehr nahe gegangen.
Das war eine harte Trennung,
die ich so nicht erwartet hatte.
Abends alleine einzuschlafen,
ist nicht so cool.
Es ist schön, wenn du nach Hause
kommst und dich jemand erwartet,
wenn jemand für dich da ist.
Ja, das fehlt.
* Er pfeift. *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ich habe noch immer
den Netflix-Account von Bigna,
das ist ein Vorteil.
Ist der Weg als Aussteiger
ein einsamer Weg?
Er ist so einsam,
wie du ihn dir gestaltest.
Ich hatte das Glück,
dass ich in der Gastronomie arbeite.
Dadurch kann ich sehr schnell
sehr viele soziale Kontakte knüpfen.
Ich bin schon ...
... an gewissen Punkten
in meinem Leben einsam gewesen,
aber das
kennt jeder von uns irgendwann.
Dadurch,
dass ich auch sehr sozial bin,
oder das
wenigstens von mir behaupte,
ging es recht schnell,
bis ich wieder
ziemlich gute soziale Kontakte fand.
Ey, Bro!
* Lebhafte Klezmer-Volksmusik *
Samuel Friedmans Leben
für die Freiheit -
ein Ablösungsprozess von Gott,
eine Suche nach sich selbst.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Roger Schmid - 2022